una de las enfermeras EA de banda ancha o
tiempo para pagar tan poco apreciado y
antes de que ella pandémica mire donde esta eso
son 7 kilos 26 millones son
profesionales la hora detrás de los sueños en
se adopta la primera línea son
el treinta por ciento dice que quiere bloquear
Prof Simone cono porate doble ataque
ante él segunda invitación y consejo
enfermería occidental internacional
Felipe Vaya vamos a firmar
de la que estamos renunciando a la
la noticia era hijo enfermera es
liberados y son mi paga por correlaciones
hay otro porque lo queria asi que aun lo tengo
tonto que es poli no puedo llegar allí
suceder Red neuronal basada en la calle
Esto representa un aumento hasta medianas de
las enfermeras cuidan el centro del mundo
afirma que el problema se agrava en masa en
países como filipinas india porque si
siempre rojo son contratados por
paises mas ricos pero eso siempre
sensacional que mama por todos lados
el mundo con el resto de la población que
apurado que me guiaba la luz
el propósito del túnel por el Conectar a
Ítalo luego aumentó a alquilar casas en
Acción Mundial de ellos a Lusa para decirle a la
menos consciente o 15 mil de estos
profesionales que murieron porque Vivi
aquí no está desde el comienzo de la era
pandemia los números reales probablemente
mucho más grande este año